هذا مفهوم رائع
تقدم شركة فرونتير إيرلاينز صفقة كل ما يمكنك الطيران مقابل
600 دولار في السنة ، يبدو أن الذهاب وايلد ممر
يبدو جيدًا جدًا لدرجة يصعب تصديقها ،
فقد ترغب في قراءة الأحرف الدقيقة ولكن
قد يكون خيارًا رائعًا
للمسافرين الدائمين ، فإليك النقاط البارزة التي
تدفعها 600 مقابل عام من الرحلات غير المحدودة
ابتداءً من الربيع المقبل بالإضافة إلى ضرائب ورسوم
تبلغ حوالي 15 دولارًا.
ألف دولار يمكنك الحصول
على الكثير من الوجهات للاختيار من بينها ،
يمكنك مشاهدة العديد من المدن من الساحل إلى الساحل
حتى في المكسيك ولكن هناك
تواريخ انقطاع وتلك النقاط الحمراء حوالي 56
منها تشمل عطلات نهاية الأسبوع الطويلة ، لذلك
عليك أن تكون مرنًا ، ففاز فرونتير أيضًا
'  لا تؤكد خططك حتى اليوم
السابق للسفر ، ولكن إذا كنت تستطيع أن تكون
عفويًا ، فقد يكون ذلك بالنسبة لك ، أعني
جين ما رأيك في ذلك ، فأنا
أحبه ، فأنا أحبه لأنه إذا
لم يكن لدي أطفال ، فأنا أشعر بذلك.  أنا
سيكون 100 في ذلك ، لم يكن لديك وظيفة
وأطفال وحيوانات أعني أنني أشعر بذلك
لأنك تعلم أنك تحتاج فقط إلى
مثل يوم الجمعة أو يوم الإثنين ، فقط
احصل على واحدة وأشعر أنني لا أعرف أنه
يمكنك  العمل حوله ويمكنك الذهاب إلى
كل هذه الأماكن أعتقد أنه سيكون
رائعًا أيضًا أعتقد أنها فكرة رائعة
أعتقد أن الناس سينجذبون إليها